好 婉婷说他们的研究部门在开会的时候
总经说是你们产业信心不足
产业说是你们总经现在太混乱
好 但不要担心
因为10月婉婷认为还是会光辉10月
对不对来请教婉婷了
因为我们都说9月有魔咒
本来以为会没事
结果看来魔咒真的来了
但是10月的话
以前的涨率是高的
现在可以期待
你现在在备战的时候要去看PCB战了
去年看完有很多的收获
所以你认为今年会抢赚的是升级这一块
对 好
那我们先来看一下大盘
是
因为明天一早
已经来不及
大家来不及做决定了
是
就是下好离售
下好离售
所以年清晨就要来开牌
是
然后FED到底会怎么做
嗯
好 然后现在归纳就是
不升级跟升级
可是市场普遍认为会升一满
对啊
这个是FED Watch的利率图
是
好 然后所以可以看得出来
9月份預期會升一馬
對 已經是板上釘釘的感覺
12月在一馬
恐怖的事
到明年中
總共升四馬
這就有點可怕了
到明年中繼續升
對 因為你知道上禮拜
其實那個Fight Watch
只有升兩馬
對
然後後來因為週末的時候
就是戰爭還有油價要上去
所以它這個就變了
然後一變大家就害怕
然後週末三巨頭一講話
大家就害怕
雪上加霜
沒錯 其實是情緒的問題
然後以基本面來看
我們看到第四季的拉貨
就是非常好
而且上週
那個OpenAI的Track GPT 6
就是那個Extra
它才告訴大家說
我算力 我賣太好了
我算力不夠
所以我要暫停新戶訂閱
所以實際上AI的發展是好的
我們沒有看到它的停滯
然後廠商們會這樣講
其實我認為只是做一個提醒
好 所以今天晚上
或明天清晨
我們要看升息不升息
後面會怎麼反應
若不升息
然后这个WASH
他会后记者会讲的
比较偏隔派
就是通膨可控
也是短暂性的
因为毕竟油价的上下
就像上礼拜跟这礼拜的
差异性这么大
所以他如果是短暂性的
他这个讲法
然后再加上再次的流动性
其实还没有你想象中
除了大发债之外
10月之后就压力不会那么大了
如果是这个状态
我认为就会是利多
那就真的就V转
是
大行情来了
光辉10月来了
好
那如果他有点偏硬
他說持續我要打擊通膨當作目標
他不去講通膨的是短暫還是長的
他只告訴你說打擊通膨
那就是不明顯可是略為便宜
所以我覺得就會比較偏向中性
可能就還是盤整
然後如果生意馬
因為現在就是大家已經認為會生意馬了
所以生意馬其實叫做符合預期
可能會利空出境
好 所以如果他生意馬
然後講話比較偏格
就是這個生意馬只是我預防性生息
其實通膨還可控
那就沒事
那我觉得也会偏多
也是差不多利空出境了
好 那如果升一码又偏硬
好
那大家就是可能要
再谨慎一点
皮绷紧了是不是
对 可是因为市场
已经预期要升四码了
对
所以如果是升一码
然后后面还是维持
升三码的这个预期
其实也是在预期内
对 然后这三条线怎么看
就蓝色的话是
是台股指数
然后红色是直立率
然后黄色是油价
那今年油价上去是因为战争然后油价上去因为大家通膨预期会好 所以你在交易值美債的時候你也擔心未來會升息所以殖利率就
今年的
看起來油跟殖利率的走勢
是有一點一步一去
然後最近其實也是
可是我們會發現說
殖利率就算往上
有這個通膨預期
升息預期出來
可是股價
在行情業績好的時候
應該說業績好的時候
行情也會好
就像今年第二季
對
其實那時候油價上去
但是台股还是涨
对 因为整个基本面更好
对 所以关键是
升息不是关键
关键是基本面够好
那所谓基本面好
它是靠AI支撑
就AI订单够强
这些AI大厂能赚得到钱
所以基本上我会觉得
行情还是比较正面的
因为订单真的很强
而且会那么多的筹资计划
就是为了明后年的营收啊
对 没错
所以这个刚刚其实
朱老师已经讲比较多
所以我其实只是想要讲
就是量缩
大家会觉得说
大家害怕
所以量缩
可是其实量就是供需
也没有人卖
我一直觉得
它就是撑在一个四万五
对 所以没有破四万五
然后又量缩
缩到这个极致
刚好明天开见证账之后
我觉得一切就结束了
所以我比较倾向就是
就算下礼拜还是盘整盘
那中秋节变盘之后
光辉十月就来了
哎呦 好啊
刚好中秋节就在月底
对
是
對 好
所以接下來十月份
就是會進入到PCB展
TPCN秀
是
然後所以我今天在之前
在想說今天要來跟大家分享什麼時候
我就想到上個月半導體展
然後看完之後我還滿開心的
因為我覺得很多晶片的發展趨勢
它會讓很多設備啦
製程啦 材料廠商
其實都會有機會
而且因為製程的難度變難
然後它的製程流程變得更長
所以會進來的人
比我想的還多
有一些東西我也有學到
好 那PCB展TVC Show
它有可能會有新東西
我現在可能不知道
可是去年此時
就是蠻多人一直在跟我講說
晶片越來越大
然後PCB會越來越半腦體化
然後就因為這句話
然後讓我發現了
誒 宰版
宰版的商機
會受惠
所以我現在可能理解的PCB
還是今年以來累積的
但是有可能10月
看完PCB展之後
我会有一些不同的想法
但我以现在的
我的认知来跟大家分享
好 然后再来就是
我先讲第一个简单的
就是八月营收
因为这个是比较短线的
那短线上你会发现
上游全部创高
全部创历史新高
对
然后有两间公司的
除了创高以外
比我想的还要更强
第一个是富桥
富桥 优于预期
对 因为它新才能开除
然后今年不 其实很缺
今年缺
但是未来不会
我每次你知道
我就会一直有那种
要一直去解释
去解释
这个逻辑是什么
对 就是
布金也很缺
但是未来会慢慢的不缺
因为产能开出来
好 然后
而且它在这个供电里面
它是不是最缺的
我当初认为最缺的是铜箔
是 铜箔
嗯 不过它看起来营收比我想的好
对 然后再来就是腾辉
腾辉电子
好 铜箔基板的
对 那主要是因为
台光台药没有新产能
所以他的AI太好
然後他就把中低階丟出來
丟出去了
好 所以他受惠了
臉貌跟騰輝因為之前駕動率是比較低的然後瞬間受惠他的營收跳升的幅度就会比较强所以这个是短线上有时候它比我们想的更强的时候
股价会有一些反应
这短期的
可是如果我们要看长线布局
因为我自己比较喜欢看长线的东西
这种短线上的
我觉得比较难精准的抓到
好 所以长线上的话
我就会去看规格升级
因为今年是缺货
然后供需是很涨价
所以很多公司的营收
动能会非常强
可是当你知道今年
供需失衡的时候
厂商会开始扩产
所以明年产能
基本上下半年
会陆续开出之后
这个供需的压力
会没有今年这么紧
我认为重点就会回到
凯光店身上
对 因为它过去在材料领先上
一直都保有比较强的地位
好 所以今年它可能
某些时间点不是
大家关注的重点
尤其第二季到第三季
因为它的报价长势
可能没有低阶的来得多
对 但是它的规格升级
就会有优势
然后另外南亚的部分
它虽然是
过去被我们认知是中低阶的公司
但是因为公司它是垂直整合
然后所以它在
每一段都有利润的情况下
它的整体利润率会提升
然后还有就是南亚希望万道超车
所以它M9、M10这一块
我认为是题材性上会有机会
好 然后台虹的部分就是PTFE
是
对 我不知道它今年
因为年底才会确定
那我没有办法确定它会不会进去
可是这个材料它的
材料特性非常好
所以就算今年没进去
我认为明年又会再被
拿出来讲
对
一定会每年被考虑
是
对
然后所以它现在是PTFE的领先厂商
那明年会不会因为台光台药
他们也开始切进PTFE
然后所以变成明年看后年
它的优势会
这个就要明年再看
但是我相信在展览上
可以得到一些答案
好 等于短期上面
对不对 有外衣效应
所以中低階的反而漲的
可能比这些高阶技术领先的
还要多
可是明年一定要回来看
这些高阶技术领先的厂商
对 是
对 然后所以这就PK
之前它涨很多的时候
真的欸 然后都不晓得
因为这没有获利
没有立刻拉起来
它有一段 应该是这一段
这一段抬光就相对比较弱
对 然后所以当后来
我觉得它涨有点过头了
再加上就是PTFE
可能没有办法那么确定
或者是不见得会
赢家通吃的时候
其实它反而这边
我觉得有点超低
对 而且材料领先
然后台光电除了
就是在原本的PCB的CCO之外
它今年底
它的载版的CCO会开出
是 产能会开出来
对 所以它会切进去BT的CCO
所以它会有一个新的领域
对 我觉得这个对它也是
业绩也是会有帮助
也是会加分的
然后我把金珠跟Naya放在一起
是因为Naya虽然有做CCO
但是它有做布跟同波
对
然后所以布跟同波
虽然明年我说不太会再涨价
可能涨价会趋缓
但是因为不容易叠价
目前业务的发展还很强
所以我认为不容易叠价
会变成它布有利润
同波有利润
CCL有利润
所以它的利润率
就会相对的通胞
因为它是垂直成的厂商
所以它的获利
还是会往上涨
而且跳的还蛮多的
那经济的部分
就是HVLP4这一块
那第四季年底
新产能开出之后
明年的获利也会有机会倍增
好 但法人為什麼那麼不喜歡金居
這個我是看投信和外資
都幾乎沒有再大量採買金居
我覺得是因為就是它的數字強度不夠強技術夠好但強度還沒有拉出來那下游的部分的話展場不會有比較不會有下游出來展
對 所以我就把它列出來
就是重新歸納一下
就是各自題材
那AI的部分的話
其實重點就是在ASIC PCB
然後還有光模塊
會是接下來的重點
還有天上的衛星
好 所以像金像電 真頂滑通
他們在往第四季去走
他們的訂單
会从题材开始转向真实的数字
那最近滑通股价比较弱
是因为Apple
它的销售有点延连
拉货有点延连
所以它营收动能一直出不来的情况下
我觉得股价比较稳
可是随着到第四季
Apple开始量产之后
然后光模块卫星开始有点贡献
那基本上我觉得第四季的动能就会转强
好 你有给电影一个圈圈
其实电影蛮多产物朋友爱问的
我知道
所以我可以
就刚好今天趁机来讲
它其实就是今年本来
大家对它的期待
就是我之前讲说第四季会有机会
因为它产能开了
然后新平台都
它都有送认证
然后公司的企图性很强
可是我们其实不太确定说会不会过
然后后来看起来就是
没有过
因为它过去没有这样的经验
所以它需要多一点时间再
它需要多一点时间再去认证
所以它的认证时间点
就是可能要等到下一次
那为什么我说忧郁期
因为单纯这个是在讨论八月营收
它八月营收
可能它毕竟有產能了
所以它去接了一些單
所以它8月營收
比我們想的來得好
那最近股價在打底
可能就等著它
下一次送認證的時間點
再來做一次夢
好 這就是希望跟失望一線之隔
對 對
可是在有希望的時候
我不能說它絕對沒有
對 所以在一開始我們在提
就是有一點N的概念
它上去是在做
有希望這件事情
那掉下來就是因為它
這一次沒有顧 對
好 有定你的朋友就斟酌啦
因為它要等下一次
可能才會重新做夢
對 然後這邊是PCB設備股
然後展覽的話會有設備
那通常展覽除了
我們剛剛在講的這個CCL跟材料之外
設備股跟一些化工材料也會進來
那因為其實我覺得設備股
在未來兩年大擴產的皇朝之下
其實這四檔都是很靈活的公司
大量亞太金屬 穆德 昌廣
對 而且他們不單單只是做PCB設備
像大量也有切到板腦梯
然後像MUD其實它有做半導體光學檢測
對 然後載版的部分的話是長廣
它的載版設備的壓核
所以明年才能開出
它的獲利成長線就會大跳升
對 所以這個都是可以在展前
可以去關注的
然後最後就是做一個小小的結論
就是因為大家還蠻愛說
滑通 普加一直不動
就是我剛剛講的
營收一直出不來
因為這兩檔算是8月營收
沒有再去創高的
對 對
然後他們的題材性其實都沒有變
整頂就是光模塊加AI PCB
然後加iPhone的摺疊機
那滑通的部分就是光模塊加衛星
對 都沒有變
然後只是唯一就是
有時候拉貨時間點會延遲
那有可能跟廠商還沒有出過
譬如說像V3
衛星V3還沒有發射
那也有可能是因為缺布缺銅箔
然後導致缺C-C-Sale
然後導致大家先給AI
然後滑通的某些東西
可能就還來不及出
是 對 大概是這樣
可是數字之後都會再出來
好 所以這些在城前的
並沒有看壞後面的數字
他們數字開出來比較慢一點
也錯
大家也不妨
如果有耐性的朋友
可以考慮這種還沒有大噴的
對
非常謝謝婉婷